et qui fait vomir de tout les temps.
Je suis sur le point de vous montrer des chose
que vous aurez du mal à oublier,
mais tout ça au nom de la science.
Avant tout, pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas ce que je fais,
si vous creusez jusqu'à l'essence même,
vous me définiriez comme un beatboxer
(Beatbox) Yo, par exemple...
voici un exemple :
(Beatbox)
(Changement de rythme)
(Fredonne un air)
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Et en étant un beatboxer,
ça signifie que professionnellement,
je dépends à 100 % de la --
(Beatbox) flexibilité de la voix humaine non filtrée.
Pendant des années, mes contemporains et moi avons répondu à des questions comme
« Oh mon Dieu, c'est magnifique.
Quand as-tu compris que tu pouvais faire ça ? »
Après m'être entraîné pendant des centaines et milliers d'heures...
(Rires)
« Et quel est ton vrai travail ? »
« Beatboxer à plein temps, votre honneur. »
Mais il y a une question qu'on me pose assez souvent
et il est un peu plus compliqué d'y répondre,
et c'est « comment tu le fais --
comment tu fais ces bruits ? »
Eh bien, la mémoire musculaire me dit comment positionner mes lèvres
pour --
(Beatbox)
Mais je n'ai aucune idée du méchanisme profond des choses.
Vous savez, tous ces trucs flasques et qui pendouillent
et comment ils interagissent --
(Rires)
de manière à me permettre --
(Beatbox)
Pour employer une métaphore,
je sais conduire,
c'est juste que je ne sais pas ce qu'il y a en dessous du capot.
J'ai donc décidé de le découvrir
et d'inviter un public de 5 000 inconnus captifs,
quelques caméras gênantes,
tous ceux qui regardent en ligne et leur historique de navigation,
dans un endroit où même les rencontres les plus intimes n'ont pas été...
ma gorge.
Et pour m'aider à faire ça,
j'aimerais appeler sur scène un invité très spécialisé
du Queensland Voice Center,
un homme qui a été dans ma bouche plus de fois que je voudrais bien admettre
une légende du larynx,
ORL et chirurgien du larynx,
Matthew Broadhurst.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
MB : Merci, Tom, Merci.
Et une très bonne soirée à tous.
C'est un plaisir d'être sur la scène de TEDx ce soir.
(Rires)
Pfou !
TT : Il ne se chauffe pas les mains.
Ce n'est pas si intime que ça.
MB : Nous avons commencé il y a quelques temps à explorer le monde
et la gorge --
de ce beatboxer extraordinaire
pour comprendre comment une gamme si vaste de sons est humainement possible.
Et ce qu'on a découvert --
ces gants vont dans la bouche --
et ce qu'on a découvert était absolument incroyable.
Même après mes deux ans de chirurgie du larynx
à la fac de médecine d'Harvard
avec le professeur de renommée mondiale Steven Zeitels,
nous n'avions vu rien de si extraordinaire ou fascinant
et c'est ce que nous vous montrerons ce soir.
(Rires)
Bien, donc pour ceux qui sont un peu sensibles,
les prochaines 10 minutes environ seront de plus en plus graphiques
et peuvent vous retourner l'estomac, alors allons-y.
TT : le seau est là, au cas où.
(Rires)
MB : Donc lors de la production d'un son,
nous utilisons les cordes vocales pour prendre de l'air des poumons
pour le transformer ensuite en colonne d'air vibrant dans la gorge.
En le comparant à une trompette,
il y a l'embouchure -- donc les cordes vocales --
et le pavillon est la gorge.
Si l'on retire la tête,
si on enlève un peu de cou
en laissant le buste seulement avec les cordes vocales qui vibrent,
voici le son que vous produiriez.
(Son de flatulence)
TT : (Ton aigu)
MB : Assez difficile pour communiquer, heureusement la gorge est là.
Nous avons tous ces tissus mous,
qui donnent en effet toute l'incroyable dynamique du son
que vous écouterez ce soir.
Maintenant, celui-ci est un laryngoscope rigide.
TT : Hmm..t'es curieux.
(Rires)
MB : Je sais, je sais.
10 millimètres de diamètre,
cela donne la plus haute résolution possible d'image du larynx.
Nous l'avons attaché à un stroboscope ici
et un microphone capteur.
Ce micro captera les fréquences
et cela nous permettra de vous montrer comment le tout fonctionne.
Bien, peut-on éteindre les lumières ?
TT : (Ton bas)
MB : Allumez la lumière ici.
TT : (Sons aigus et bas)
MB : La fréquence du son est appairée au stroboscope.
Il s'agit de la lumière clignotante que vous voyez dans le verre.
TT : (Son bas)
MB : Celui-ci est à environ 80 Hz.
Nous pouvons aussi le prendre,
et laisser la phase du strobe et du son hors syncro.
Ainsi, nous pouvons capter en temps réel,
et en ralenti l'activité des tissus vibrants.
Quand on l'applique au larynx,
nous obtenons une vibration fluide des cordes vocales vue au ralenti.
Voila là où on arrivera et ce que l'on fera.
D'accord, tu es prêt ?
TT : Ouaip
(Rires)
MB : Ok, donc allons-y.
Nous allons jeter un coup d'œil au larynx.
(Rires)
Tire la langue
C'est vraiment difficile de ne pas s'étouffer.
Dis « e ».
TT : (Chantant) E --
MB: Tout en bas vous voyez les cordes vocales,
comme des petites cordelettes.
(Rires)
Maintenant regardez la peau sur le cou
et vous verrez que la puissance de la lumière pénètre la peau.
Bien, on peut rallumer, s'il vous plaît ?
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Bien, fais-nous un beau « e ».
TT : (Chantant) E.
(Rires)
(Exclamation du public)
MB : Voici les cordes vocales en vibration :
environ 120 Hertz.
Elles se sont donc entrechoquées 120 fois par seconde
rien que pour produire ce son.
Et nous pouvons aussi voir qu'elles sont parfaitement normales.
Le fait de beatboxer, de produire ces sons pendant des années
comme Tom le fait --
n'a absolument pas causé de dégâts.
Vraiment remarquable.
Très bien.
Ok.
TT : (Son aigu)
Le voilà.
MB : Regardez comment les cordes vocales changent d'un aigü à un grave.
Vous les verrez longues et minces puis courtes et épaisses.
Pense à un « e ».
TT : (Son aigü puis grave) E.
MB : Voilà.
MB : Vous remarquerez que sa gamme vocale est si extrême --
bien plus que tous les autres artistes avec qui j'ai travaillé --
la machine ne peut en fait pas capter les sons vraiment aigus.
TT : ( Son aigu)
MB : Mais nous savons que le sifflement s'obtient au alentour des 2 092 hertz.
Cela signifie que les cordes vocales,
bien au delà des 2000 fois par seconde,
s'entrechoquent pour produire ce son.
C'est vraiment extraordinaire.
A bien réfléchir, elles ne font que 15 mm de long,
c'est à peine la longueur de votre pouce.
C'est incroya --
(Rires)
C'est surprenant que cet organe puisse faire ça.
Maintenant nous allons introduire le laryngoscope flexible.
Celui-ci est plus graphique.
TT : Il l'a acheté au SEXPO.
(Rires)
MB : Ça n'était pas prévu dans le script.
(Applaudissements)
TT : C'est d'occasion.
(Rires)
MB : Nous avons dû mesurer parfaitement ce passage
pour exécuter l'anesthésie locale.
Il faut endormir le nez, insérer la caméra.
Ça ne permettra pas l'émission d'une partie des sons
mais nous avons ainsi un bon aperçu de ce qu'il se passe.
Alors accrochez-vous et voyons ce qu'on peut faire.
(Exclamations du public)
Maintenant nous allons au fond du nez.
Et vous voyez ainsi le voile du palais.
Beaucoup des sons qu'on produit chaque jour,
même les plus simples,
sont incoyablement complexes.
Le son « kh » par exemple .
C'est quand le voile du palais se colle exactement à l'arrière du nez.
Si vous le dites fort cinq fois,
vous sentirez votre voile du palais claquer contre le fond de la gorge.
Kh, kh, kh, kh, kh, kh.
Bien, voici à quoi ça ressemble quand Tom le fait.
TT : Kh, kh, kh, kh, kh, kh.
« A cacophony of cackling kookaburras et cockatoos à Kakadu
couldn't quite quit ketamine ».
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
MB : Dans le monde de la Beatbox,
ceci est utilisé pour toute sorte d'effets différents.
Je peux t'aider.
TT : Ça va, nous sommes professionnels.
(Rire)
(Beatbox)
MB : D'accord.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
Maintenant nous allons descendre encore un peu.
Merci d'éteindre les lumières
Prêtez attention à la lumière quelques part dans la bouche
Vous pourrez voir exactement où la caméra se trouve.
(Rires)
TT : (En chantant)
Surprise.
(Rires)
MB : Bien
(Exclamation du public)
Ce que vous voyez est la base de la langue.
Sur les côtés de l'écran,
c'est le pharynx.
La paroie musculaire,
et enfin, le canal sombre c'est le larynx.
TT : Oh, nous devrions reallumer la lumière, non ?
Oui, bonne idée.
Ça fait un peu peur sans.
MB : Lumière svp, merci.
Bien.
En ayant examiné 15 000 larynx et gorges dans ma carrière,
je peux garantir que celle de Tom est anatomiquement normale
C'est juste sa manière unique d'exploiter tous les muscles et tissus mous
qui lui permet de faire tous ces sons magnifiques que vous écouterez.
Nous allons décortiquer certains d'entre eux.
TT : Je vous jure qu'il est là. Absolument.
(Rires)
Ok.
(Sons aigus)
(Hululement)
MB : Ce qu'il fait, il change la forme
et la longueur de la colonne d'air en vibration
en exploitant les contractions rythmiques des muscles
pour générer tous les sons que vous écoutez.
(Beatbox)
(Rires)
(Sons graves)
MB : et maintenant les mouvements rythmiques --
ce sont les cartilages aryténoïdes,
qui font un va-et-vient pour créer ces différents sons.
TT : (Sons graves)
MB : On appelle ça la basse du sphincter.
(Rires)
Vous voyez qu'en abaissant tous les tissus --
il donne vie à des notes de basse très graves.
Bien, avec l'anesthésie locale en cours,
un gros tuyau noir dans le nez,
nous écouterons un peu de son repertoire
et nous verrons tout en direct.
Nous allons bouger --
attention.
TT : Tu peux le remonter juste un petit peu.
(Rires)
TT: (Beatbox)
Peut-être encore un peu --
(Rires)
D'accord, bien, c'est bon je pense.
(Beatbox) Tout mes piaulements qui sont profonds,
aussi profond que les abysses --
check this.
(Beatbox)
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements)
(Beatbox)
On commence par les bases pour construite une séquence.
(scratching)
Oui, parfait.
(Beatbox)
(son de trompette)
(Beatbox) Revenons aux bases.
(Beatbox)
(Beatbox) Vous connaissez le son.
(Beatbox) Faites un peu de bruit.
(Applaudissements et acclamations)
(Sifflements)
TT : Merci beaucoup.